[Music]
the ingredients are not important
because they are tasty they
are important because of what they mean
for a certain culture in their origin they
maintain much of our identity
we go in search of the unknown to
make it known to do our part to
understand it and be able to serve it
[Music]
I am virgilio martínez  I am a very young cook at the
central restaurant
the fact that I want to travel
eat everything try everything talk to
all kinds of people in the world I think
it helps me a lot today to
understand what I do as a cook
[Music]
among the association look for acquaintances
every day we work with something that
we have used before
the territory of peru is very large and
very diverse moody's in its crumpled paper
where you will find many
microclimates and different ecosystems
we have a menu of heights where we post
update ecosystems at each height
it generates a different ecosystem and everything
it wants is put together, we return it,
we put it next to the plate  It starts at less than
10 meters then we go to other
heights until we reach the
Andes ran up to 4000 meters which is extreme
height and then we go to the Amazon
what are you going to try almost 300 products that
come from different parts of Peru and from
different heights some option  What
we use is edible clay, the
bark, the one pop, parts of the Amazon,
we use coca leaves, we use
dehydrated potatoes, herbs,
aromatic Andean herbs, a range of
chilca ccoo dye plants, and what we use
to color food. Plants that have
been used  in the textile industry and
never in gastronomy, perhaps it is not
expected in a restaurant that they think
is the fine dining,
not
a new ingredient, first a
curiosity is born and that is when we go out we have to
go out looking for it and how we find it by
talking to Andean
Amazonian communities or  going to the field and doing
a bit of collecting
unknown places their distant places that
can even be dangerous  bear here comes the
work also in a way
my name is malena martinez and I am
co-director of matter initiative
we are in cusco in moray at 3,680 meters
above sea level
matter initiative is an organization
that we created to investigate about
products about food in more than
We have
two anthropologists, a
nutritionist, an environmental economist,
a doctor, who is me, six cooks, and
we have external collaborators, the
methods of finding an ingredient are
different, sometimes we go looking for an
ingredient and suddenly you
find others, and that process  you have to go
to a scientist who helps you
identify what it is that you are
facing
we normally do not say that we
discovered because the ingredients
have already been there it is more likely
hundreds of years ago and so we
think that rather we learn from
ingredients or in everything  case
rediscover it the work that makes
matter starts  tive is, let's say, the soul of
what happens in central
would make us think that the people who come
here really want to eat from
another planet so that people feel that they
are on another planet another reality
we are not only looking to excite people
we have to take it to  another level
or the days I wake up and run the
kitchen and I find new ideas
I need very privileged processes that
I have the opportunity to cook things
that seem new to me that seem
interesting to me and that people are
accepting